lundi soir France 3 diffusait la Nuit
des Molières qui récompense les acteurs
et actrices du milieu théâtral bonsoir
et bienvenue à la 34e cérémonie des
Molières au cours de cette cérémonie
annuelle la ministre de la Culture Rima
Abdoul Malak a été prise à partie par
des artistes militantes de la CGT nous
ne sommes pas les chiens ni des chiennes
d'habitude le rôle
d'une station rien dire mais
là c'est immédiatement fait le buzz et
fait couler beaucoup d'encre mais hier
soir sur notre plateau Cyril Hanouna a
fait d'étonnant révélation sur cet
échange tout était orchestré en fait
tout était du mytho les propos qui ont
suscité de vivre réaction révélation de
Cyril Hanouna sur la séquence au Molière
nos précisions ce soir dans TPMP
[Applaudissements]
et les chéris alors on a la réponse 2 du
journaliste de challenge qui a très bien
d'enquêté
Jean-François Arnaud qui est excellent
d'ailleurs et demain il raconteront tout
dans le challenge vous allez voir c'est
la sœur demain donc voilà donc
il maintient tout il nous donne des
précisions
il confirme que les organisateurs ça
fait très bien que la ministre allait
intervenir intervenir et que tout était
prévu regardez écoutez
de l'organisation de
[Musique]
soirée on savait que la ministre allait
répondre et c'est pour ça que le fameux
micro était à proximité près branché
d'ailleurs on voit qu'elle fait le geste
comme si
elle le micro fonctionne mais ça
fonctionne très très bien elle le sait
parfaitement puisqu'elle parle déjà
depuis plusieurs secondes dans ce micro
là c'est le petit coup qui laisse croire
au téléspectateurs que c'est improvisé
mais c'est pas un provisé si on n'avait
pas dit ça hier Jean-François non on
s'est clairement foutu notre gueule et
il y a un autre moment où elle dit
attendez non mais attendez c'est bon on
a le temps laissez-moi parler etc donc
c'est vraiment complètement mis en scène
on croyait assister un échange spontané
en fait c'était une pièce de théâtre
alors on a voulu pousser l'enquête on a
étudié exactement on aura d'autres
sonores de Jean-François dans un instant
on a étudié comment exactement comment
la ministre avait eu un micro aussi
rapidement c'est l'avare des Molières
regarde
[Rires]
que la lutte continue et vive les
casseroles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pardon je sais que vous avez pas le
temps mais ça va
merci aux équipes merci aux équipes
alors les chiriers oui oui alors il va
plus loin le journalisme il affirme que
la ministre avait eu accès au test des
deux artistes que le qui l'ont
interpellé elle a donc plus préparé sa
réponse comme je vous le disais hier
comme elle a eu accès au texte puisque
c'était au prompteur et la production
lui a donné le texte voilà après voilà
c'est et donc elle a pu préparer parce
que je les Acheux Gérard Philippe pour
sortir la date frère tu vas voir on est
d'accord
ou pas bah bien sûr bah c'est impossible
de la boîte cultivée tout ce qu'on veut
enfin savoir que j'ai à Philippe avait
prononcé en 57 une phrase comme ça au
milieu de l'année comme ça c'est
vraiment qu'elle avait toutes les
questions avant elle savait elle avait
le discours c'est honteux c'est ça toi
Anissa toi Gérard Philipe c'est qui
Gérard Philip
balancer un ministre c'est un premier
ministre
non mais Gérard Philippe l'ancien
Premier ministre il y a la barbe blanche
ça t'a choqué qu'elle soit au concert de
Jay-Z bah franchement fait sa vie mais
bon en ce moment c'est pas trop le
moment quoi pas mal donc pas mal
pas mal elle a un regard sur
l'actualité
écoutez ce que dit le journal
le texte qui était lu au prompteur par
les deux comédiennes et deux artistes
qui a été validée même écrit par la CGT
a été transmis à 18h
l'après-midi des Molières aux
organisateurs et que ce texte a été
communiqué à la ministre
pas si elle a eu le sur papier ou si on
lui a lu mais elle connaissait ce texte
et la préparer sa réponse
voilà donc elle connaît était le texte
elle a préparé sa réponse Jean-Mi toi
qui était pas là hier qu'est-ce que tu
en penses non en même temps c'est moi je
trouve ça plutôt pas mal qu'elle puisse
répondre voilà j'aurais préféré que ça
soit spontané et que ça sort du cœur
plutôt que ça soit préparé par ses
conseillers communication
qu'est-ce que tu penses de ça moi je
pense que nous prend pour des cons quoi
d'accord
elle a vraiment des avis sans concession
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui tout le monde a peur depuis
qu'on a fait les révélations parce que
et c'est vrai que c'est là qu'on voit la
puissance de TPMP donc merci à vous les
chéris parce que quand des journalistes
ont sorti c'est vrai voilà mais quand
TPMP s'est mis sur les côtes de cette
affaire c'est vrai que tout le monde
tremblait c'est un truc de fou Gilles
Verdez c'est ça il va nous le rappeler
aujourd'hui tous les producteurs sont
montés au créneau pour défendre
effectivement la ministre c'était
terreur à tous les états alors en plus
Emmanuel Macron qui lui a dit bravo
d'avoir réagi donc du coup ça met en
porte-à-faux le président parce qu'il
dit bravo une réaction qui est bidonnée
on la prend maintenant donc du coup du
plus haut jusque au niveau de la
ministre c'est branle-bas de combat tous
les étages comment essayer de récupérer
une affaire qui de toute façon est
foutue je vous le dit très clairement il
paraît qu'ils sont tous en stress tout
ça bah c'est terrible vous rendez compte
c'est c'est tout elle symbolisait pour
Emmanuel Macron enfin une ministre qui
prend la parole et c'était bidonné c'est
terrible alors regardez regardez
regardez ce qu'il y a notre journaliste
du gouvernement de la tutelle etc c'est
bien normal l'organisateur
à Paris c'est pas la
[Musique]
grande était de production qui travaille
en grande partie toute l'année pour le
secteur pas envie de
le qu'on fait une petite magouille donc
c'est vrai que tout le monde tout le
monde a peur et personne m'a dit
le texte
je
qui a donné le texte à la réponse en
plus j'adore les producteurs Jacques
Clément tu vois producteur et ça fait
aussi acte 4 je les adore voilà après
voilà ils sont dans un ah c'est
compliqué pour eux oui on va on va vous
donner la réponse des producteurs et du
président de la cérémonie des Molières
non mais en fait c'est que de la com
c'est au lieu de faire ce coup d'éclat
pour avoir trois applaudissements et
faire une recherche sur Wikipédia pour
savoir qui a dit quoi en 57 elle aurait
dû rigoler comme tout le monde pendant
la cérémonie et vraiment recevoir c'est
c'est comédiennes ces intermittents qui
avaient un message à faire passer là
c'est tout l'inverse en fait c'est il y
a un discours de plateau télé
ou non mais pas elle là elle aurait dû
faire l'inverse ne pas parler pendant
l'émission C'est un qui a un discours de
plateau télé et en dehors tout le monde
s'en fout rien ne se passe alors du
faire l'inverse alors juste tu pourrais
remercier notre ami je suis
Jean-François Arnaud le challenge qui a
très bien manqué et vous retrouverez ça
demain dans challenge juste petit truc
avant que vous répondiez parce que j'ai
la réponse de du président de la
cérémonie Molière Jean-Marc du monté
évidemment alors il ne confirme pas nos
informations ni les informations de de
Jean-François selon lui rien n'était
prévu au conducteur et le ministre
n'aurait jamais eu accès au texte des
militantes néanmoins il explique qu'il
n'est pas impossible que ministre est
plus préparé sa sortie en amont chaque
année des militants prennent la parole
concernant le micro il explique que sur
toutes les cérémonies de la des
assistants réalisateurs avec des micros
prêt à intervenir à tout moment
voilà proche du pouvoir lui il défend sa
cérémonie je l'aime bien lui absolument
mais c'est un gars c'est très bien mais
c'est un discours de circonstances quand
même et à demi-mots mais qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé sans y aller tout à fait
elle a peut-être pu préparer parce qu'il
veut pas avouer donc il est pris un peu
en porte-à-faux on aura la SDG qui
parlera dans un instant pour l'instant
je voudrais juste vous donner la
réaction des producteurs et la SDG
prendra la parole juste après voilà les
suceurs du gouvernement
[Applaudissements]
personne tu vois personne bah non bah
surtout bah qui peut venir je sais pas
vous dites ça à moi alors je vous
réponds
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pas regardé alors tiens Jacques Clément
alors là aussi dans la réponse du
producteur on voit qu'on a compris et
Jacques vraiment je l'aime bien en plus
alors les créateurs d'actes 4 production
donc la société de production derrière
les Molières il dit rien n'a jamais été
organisé une orchestré avec la ministre
la seule chose qui a été prévue ce
soir-là c'est le discours des deux
comédiennes et c'était au prompteur donc
forcément vous croyez vraiment que la
ministre elle a passé au prompteur elle
va pas dire qu'est-ce qu'elles vont dire
les deux comédiennes ce soir mec c'est
une demande de la CGT à laquelle nous
avons souscrit
avec la chaîne donc voilà donc ils ont
dit donc ils ont dit ils ont dit ils ont
donné donc au prompteur donc la ministre
elle avait où elle s'est cramée les
Chéries c'est sur Girard Philippe voilà
elle le savait alors sur l'histoire du
micro il se défend aussi tout le monde
sait dans le monde du spectacle que dans
ce type de programme il y a toujours un
assistant de chaque côté de la scène au
cas où il se passerait quelque chose au
cas où on aurait besoin d'évacuer ou en
cas d'incident imprévus c'est pareil
victoire de musique il dit aussi sa
fille Disney pas du tout prévu voilà
après ce qui était prévu c'est ce que je
vous ai raconté hier c'est qu'en fait
les deux jeunes filles avaient donné
leur texte au prompteur quand vous
donnez le texte au prompteur vous devez
le donner très tôt sachez-le c'est voilà
parce qu'il y a des répétitions etc donc
forcément tout le monde a eu accès au
texte des des deux jeunes filles donc
forcément la la ministre à Ultex donc
elle a pu préparer avec ses équipes la
réponse et bien sûr qu'elle savait très
bien la ministre quel est l'intervenir à
la fin du discours de de oui là alors ce
que je voulais vous dire moi en fait
c'est quand mais c'est en partie vrai
tout ce que vous avez dit mais il faut
préciser quand même certaines choses la
cérémonie a démarré à 19h45 elle était
enregistrée en léger différé la
diffusion tout simplement parce que pour
raccourcir les discours trop longs et
justement le coût du micro là soi-disant
les trois secondes oui micro est apparu
en fait ça a duré beaucoup plus
longtemps et ça a été coupé au montage
quant au discours qui était préparé par
la CGT effectivement mais quand vous
recevez une ministre dans un truc comme
ça officiel on est obligé c'est le
protocole d'informer qui aura des
personnalités de la CGT qui allaient
s'exprimer et elle a très bien accepté
d'ailleurs donc j'étais effectivement à
18h ça a été donné le texte et à 19h45 à
la demande qu'elle a eu le texte sans
doute eu le texte ça je mais même ça
fait rien parce que la vie
était très bien mais elle était pas
obligée de répondre elle a eu envie de
répondre c'est la première fois
c'est pas grave
donc elle savait qu'elle allait parler
et que voilà mais savait que j'allais
parler bien sûr mais et c'est le
protocole de le dire elle a accepté que
tu t'exprime quand il y a des
intermittents qui viennent sur les
cérémonies parfois c'est voilà c'est
sauvage voilà c'est pas prévu
donc forcément Jean-Michel quand elle
commence à fasse par dire non d'habitude
on reste assimilé là c'est pas possible
elle fait croire que c'est spontané
alors qu'en fait croire que genre elle
se levait genre elle était irritée par
le discours elle parlait non elle savait
dès le début qu'elle allait la vérité je
sens Anissa outre
mais moi et moi ça veut vraiment non
mais je te le dis Géraldine tu regardes
là je sens que vraiment mais je te dis
ce soir elle va même pas sortir
t'inquiète pas non moi je trouve que
c'est pas en fait c'est pas un stand-up
d'être ministre de la culture c'est pas
Jamel Debbouze elle est pas là pour
faire de l'impro ou être bonne en impro
ou mauvaise en impro de la même manière
que les deux comédiennes de la CGT ont
préparé un texte on prépare une sortie
elles se sont préparées je vois pourquoi
une ministre n'aurait pas le droit de se
préparer
ce qui nous dérange Géraldine
ce qui dérange les téléspectateurs et ce
qui nous dérange ici c'est qu'elle joue
le fait que genre je suis pas au courant
ah il y a un micro ah bah attendez c'est
ça le truc en fait elle savait très bien
qu'elle allait le faire mais elle elle
joue le truc Girard Philippe genre elle
joue le truc c'est c'est improvisé mais
c'est pas c'est ce qui nous dérange
c'est c'est que c'est c'est elle le joue
si elle avait dit j'avais prévu et je
savais que vous alliez dire ça c'était
pas la même la réponse
vraiment juste se lever et dire puisque
vous me donnez ce que je peux répondre
avec d'habitude vous m'interpeller
d'habitude c'est pas notre rôle machin
là elle se lève non mais ça suffit
maintenant exactement dans sa cuisine
qu'elle est en train de faire une
omelette
qu'est-ce qu'il fait beaucoup de mal
c'est qu'en voulant faire un coup
d'éclat comme ça c'est ce que j'ai dit
hier en voulant faire un coup d'éclat en
nous faisant croire qu'elle est
naturelle et spontanée elle fait encore
plus de tort c'est ça qu'on est déjà il
y a beaucoup de Français qui sont
dégoûtés par la politique en disant que
les politiques c'est des menteurs et qui
sont ils arrêtent pas de mentir à
longueur de journée et qui sont pas
proches du peuple du peuple qui parle
pas avec le peuple d'or là elle fait
genre je vais parler avec le peuple
c'est pas vrai elle ne voulait pas
parler club c'était préparer à l'avance
ce qui nous dérange ça qui dérange
est-ce qu'il dérange beaucoup de gens
c'est genre qu'elle est genre jouer fin
à la fin
arrêtez je vais parler Daniel non non
mais c'est ça une petite phrase aurait
suffi pour une fois j'ai demandé à
prendre la parole c'était pas là et elle
joue très très gros parce qu'en fait
quand le soir les gens ont dit qu'elle
avait sauvé sa peau parce qu'elle est
quand même vraiment sur la sellette donc
là c'était un gros coup pour elle mais
avec ce doute qu'on a c'est mort là elle
est voilà
d'un coup positif c'est ça le truc bah
oui c'est ça l'histoire mais
stop stop
nous on n'est pas élus par le peuple en
fait pour faire rire les gens pour
divertir les gens évidemment qu'on a un
conducteur évidemment que là il y a
marqué à 19h31 il y aura une pub
évidemment qu'on le sait c'est c'est une
émission préparée alors il est 19h50
mais c'est pour faire rire les gens moi
je suis pas un élu du peuple on m'a pas
on m'a pas mis au pouvoir c'est pas j'ai
pas voté en fait moi une personne a voté
pour nous on est là on fait les guides
si tu veux si ça te plaît pas tu prends
ta télécommande tu changes là elle est
en train de mentir à des gens c'est ça
vas-y normalement dit que ce qu'il y a
mamie
toute seule quoi de faire ça c'est
vraiment une balle dans le panard non
mais c'est vrai parce qu'elle a été
brillante elle aurait juste apparaît
personne
il y a un problème aussi c'est que
politiquement elle a été saluée j'ai
pensé à vous aujourd'hui Cyril par de
nombreux médias et on dit le coup
d'éclat de la miniature
exactement en fait ce que j'aime aussi
c'est que j'ai vu il y a des médias qui
ont rappelé juste le producteur il dit
ah bah le producteur il nous a dit que
c'était pas préparé pour moi c'est pas
préparé
donc elle devient le symbole de ces
ministres qui réagissent alors que en
fait on sait que cette hypothèse donc là
bien sûr politiquement cher Bernard vous
me regardez d'un air bizarre
politiquement
bravo Gilles de ce que tu dis je trouve
ça très bien bravo Géraldine transcrit
cette information cette scène assistée
manuel Macron qui est en déplacement
province il y a quelqu'un dans la foule
qui est venu serrer la main qui pose une
question et qu'on apprenait après que la
question il la connaissait déjà mis le
Macron que c'était quelqu'un qui allait
lui poser il savait déjà tu serais
choqué en disant alors si quelqu'un a
compris
je vais mettre en place une cellule
vous pouvez nous appeler 24 24 si une
personne devant son écran en direct ce
soir à 20h01 a compris ce que vous
voulez dire cette personne moi-même
n'hésitez pas à nous contacter et à nous
dire pourquoi waouh
je préfère
dans toutes les villes de France voilà
les élus le peuple etc et les gens lui
posent des questions sur ma première
après coup qu'une des questions qui lui
était posée il la connaissait à l'avance
donc il avait préparé sa réponse on
serait choqué de la même façon voilà
c'est clair merde ma gueule énorme c'est
que ma gueule
oui mais oui ma gueule Géraldine c'est
que une Miss pas faire du stand-up mais
là elle fait justement de la comédie
elle prend les gens pour des cons et sur
la forme et donc sur le pont
monsieur monsieur
c'était pas ouf qui nous reste peut-être
sur un truc
du micro pardon mais vous croyez
vraiment dans une cérémonie avec une
centaine avec des centaines de personnes
c'est l'assistant réalisateur qui décide
de couper l'émission en 5 secondes en
donnant la parole c'est impossible elle
est grillée sur les vêtements ça se
passe jamais quand tu as raison ma
gueule
[Rires]
non mais ma gueule
les mecs je connais la télé et Guillaume
aussi vous croyez quoi mais tout est
orchestré c'est le relaxant réalisateur
il était là il lui attends il y a les
deux filles qui vont parler tu donneras
le micro à tel un moment vous êtes fous
quoi c'est un direct mais on fait du
direct tous les jours on sait comment ça
se passe ce qui est dommage c'est que du
coup on oublie complètement le fond de
ce qu'elle dit mais on se concentre donc
sur la forme et le le soir quand on
regarde devant sa télé on se dit waouh
exactement et voilà c'est le lendemain
il y a un effet deceptif
c'est elle qui a attendu ce piège là
son propre piège et les téléspectateurs
sont choqués parce que les
téléspectateurs ils croient Valérie
c'est ça le problème donc voilà bah oui
mais elle mérite ce retour de bâton
franchement moi je suis déçu quand elle
dit qu'elle veut pas venir ici ça je
suis déçu et ça je trouve que c'est très
grave pour un ministre de la Culture
mais ça je trouve pas que c'est pas
venir ici à la même situation
tu es toujours sur Madagascar
je suis gentil inquiétez pas
les comptes plus tard